- Listen. I have to say there's one thing.
- [Narrator] Okay.
- I wanna tell you.
Because you did a song on
the "Love Actually" soundtrack.
- Yes.
- Which is so beautiful by the way.
- It's a beautiful song.
- Oh, thank you.
I forget the song.
I love the movie.
- Well, but I almost met
you on the red carpet.
- What!
- For the premiere.
We were there.
You were four people to the right
and I couldn't get to you.
And it drove me crazy.
- What!
You were trying to get to me.
- I was, and here's why.
Because I had this amazing
friend named Stanley DeSantis.
- [Narrator] Okay.
- Who was in a TV show called
"Tales Of The City" with me.
- Yeah.
- We watched you every
week on "American Idol".
- What!
- We rooted for you
from the very beginning?
- What is happening?
(crowd cheering)
Are you serious?
- We would call each other.
He lived in Los Angeles.
I live New York.
It was like our thing, was to watch you.
And you did a 40 song at one point.
And we were like,
look at her go.
- Oh my girl.
- Girl got range.
I mean we were all over it,
and he's no longer with us,
my friend's family.
- [Narrator] Oh.
- But every time I see you,
I think of him.
- [Narrator] We love see him.
- And so it's a ...
- I can't even believe like ...
- So you mean more to
me than you ever knew.
- [Narrator] That is
the craziest thing ever
and so sweet.
But by the way,
I remember that red carpet.
- Yeah. It was intense.
- [Narrator] It was.
And I had to go after Keira Knightley.
- Oh yeah.
(woman laughing)
- And it's like red carpets
were still fairly new to me.
- I was thinking it must have been
one of your first ones.
- [Narrator] And she was
like full on like a model.
- [Narrator] Oh yeah.
- 'Cause she was posing.
- The girls who know
how to do it, I don't.
- I look like a girl scout.
- I know you're like.
- I was hi.
- I know.
- Like right after Keira Knightley,
I tried to and then I saw her like posing
and I was like, oh.
- Yeah.
- I was like I was trying.
I felt so uncomfortable 'cause
I'm never around actors.
I'm always around musicians.
- Sure.
But I remember leaning back
and looking and seeing you
like four people down
and I could never get to you
and I was so ...
So here we are.
- [Narrator] You would've made me.
- 20 years later.
- [Narrator] Feel so good like.